are you ready for out last two well now  you can finally get a taste of the  horror game to come I'm Tony and this  game spot news update is just a sample  the outlast to demo is available now on  ps4 xbox one and pc via steam you'll get  to hop into the shoes of cameraman blake  langerman who's investigating the  strange murder of a pregnant woman  alongside his wife Lynn this leads the  two of you to a really creepy farm in  the middle of the Arizona desert if all  of that sounds good to you note that you  won't have forever to download the demo  it'll only be available until November  first out last two is headed to ps4 xbox  one and pc in the first quarter of 2017  we checked out the demo at PAX East this  year and yeah it's pretty scary you can  check out GameSpot's podcast dead air to  hear more about outlast too and other  terrifying games and for all the biggest  video game news you're already in the  right place  you